mit nur 31 Jahren ist ihr Mann Ilja an
der Front gefallen als ukrainischer
Soldat an dieser Promenade am niepro in
saporicia hat Aljona procopenko die
Liebe ihres Lebens vor sechs Jahren
kennengelernt nach einigen Monaten waren
sie ein paar heirateten hatten ein
ganzes gemeinsames Leben vor sich
ich habe ihn für alles geliebt alles an
ihm war einfach großartig er war ein so
wunderbarer außergewöhnlicher Mensch
Ilja kämpfte schon seit 2014 im don-bass
als Soldat im Februar 2022 als Russland
die gesamte Ukraine Angriff meldete er
sich wieder im Oktober vergangenen
Jahres wurde er schwer verwundet kämpfte
fünf Tage im Krankenhaus um sein Leben
brustverletzung Aljona war so oft sie
durfte bei ihm versuchte zu helfen
irgendwie
wir hatten eine unglaublich enge
Verbindung wir haben einander sehr stark
gespürt und so habe ich zu Hause einfach
gesagt
iljosha atme atme komm einatmen ausatmen
einatmen ausatmen ich war hilflos
ihr Mann starb ihre Welt brach zusammen
und Aljona wurde klar dass sie das nicht
allein schafft eine Freundin heilte das
Projekt mein Liebster ich liebe auf den
Weg zu bringen nach einem Aufruf des
Stadtrats von saporicia meldeten sich
weitere Frauen eine Psychologin stellte
die Gruppe zusammen der Tod der Männer
muss mindestens vier Monate her sein
sonst ist die Trauer zu tief die sechs
Frauen treffen sich einmal in der Woche
immer an anderen Orten heute sind sie im
Garten eines Künstlers reden basteln
zusammen
wir haben unsere Träume vergessen wir
leben nicht den Träumen wir machen keine
Pläne für die Zukunft wir leben im Hier
und Jetzt und das ist schwer
bei den ersten Treffen blickten sie
zurück sie haben Briefe geschrieben an
ihre gefallenen Männer sich an das Leben
mit ihren Partnern erinnert haben
versucht den unfassbaren Schmerz in
Worte zu fassen
[Musik]
daher waren sie sehr schwer
sie sind aber äußerst notwendig um sich
nicht zu verschließen muss man alles
aussprechen danach wird es einfacher
nimmt uns mit zum Grab ihres gefallenen
Mannes
der Krieg begann brachte er seine Frau
und seine Tochter in Sicherheit nach
Polen kehrte zurück und meldete sich zur
Armee
vor sieben Monaten starb er im Don Bass
ich konnte nicht glauben dass er sterben
würde er sagte immer dass er
zurückkehren würde dass er auf jeden
Fall zurückkehren würde
du kennst mich doch ich komme wieder ich
verspreche es ich komme wieder
die Treffen mit den anderen Frauen
helfen Irina gegen die Einsamkeit sagt
die 43-Jährige geben ihr Kraft sich um
ihre 14-jährige Tochter Elina zu kümmern
aber das Gefühl der Sicherheit kann ihr
keiner zurückgeben
mit ihm waren wir wie hinter einer
Steinmauer er hat uns immer beschützt er
hat immer allen geholfen ist immer
losgezogen um alle zu unterstützen
es ist ein langer Weg zurück in das
Leben für die sechs Frauen am Anfang
jeder Gesprächsrunde erzählen sie sich
wie es ihnen in der Woche ergangen ist
erste kleine Hoffnungsschimmer
geworden
nicht mehr so ängstlich wie früher
an diesem Tag basteln sie eine Collage
sie sollen ihre Träume und Wünsche für
die Zukunft zusammenstellen
durch die Trauer verlieren wir den Bezug
zur Realität
[Musik]
diesen Bezug nicht zu verlieren
ich kann zum Beispiel auf diese Collage
schauen und mich daran erinnern was ich
früher wollte als alles gut war
es geht etwas bergauf aber Aljona sagt
auch dass sie sich verändert habe härter
geworden sei und sie hätte so gerne ein
Kind von ihrem Mann gehabt
dies noch
grundsätzlich kann man zwar alles
überleben aber dieser Schmerz ist sehr
individuell ich würde es wie ein
chronischen Schmerz beschreiben der
bleibt denn vergessen kann man das nicht
vor dem Tag an dem der Krieg vorbei ist
Angst dass die Erinnerung an ihren
gefallenen Helden wie sie ihn nennen
verblasst all das wird bei Kriegsende
aufbrechen glaubt sie
dann wird mir klar werden wie viele
Menschen ich verloren habe wie viele
Freunde ich verloren habe
die Liebe meines Lebens verloren ich
habe Angst vor dieser Erkenntnis längst
interessieren sich auch andere Frauen
für das Projekt wollen daran teilnehmen
diese Verbundenheit erleben sechs Frauen
die sich gegenseitig stützen in der wohl
schwersten Zeit ihres Lebens
[Musik]